this video is sponsored by book walker
thanks to the anime rented girlfriend
has just started to be officially
translated and you can get it right now
on
bookwalker right now they're having a
back to school campaign where you can
get up to 50
of your coins back on school live theme
manga like rent a girlfriend why the
hell are you here teacher and
many more click the link below to give
it a look and you can also use coupon
code giggup for five dollars off that's
coupon code giga for five dollars off
and you'll definitely want to give this
one a shot because
well it's exactly what we're talking
about today
wait a second before we attack each
other and tear ourselves to shreds like
a pack of maniacs let's just
open the sack first and see what's
actually in it it might not even be
worth the trouble
what are you saying i'm not sure maybe
hi
okay it's worth it
in anime the battle for best girl is a
never-ending war that will continue
raging on until the end of time
and in no other genre is this battle
more fierce more
cutthroat more unforgiving than the
harem genre
good girls bad girls shy girls my girl
forget what you think of other genres
harem anime with the truest and original
tournament arc where unlike all this
other pansy ass oh look i can't fight
you anymore because the tournament's
been suspended
[ __ ] there will and can only be one
winner
one happy ending one best girl and there
is no battle that is longer or bloodier
so you gotta pick your side carefully
however
sometimes there comes a girl so powerful
so undeniably ahead of the competition
that no amount of nerfs or balance
patches can offset
how much she's broken the system a girl
that is not only clearly best girl of
her own show but unless some ultra mega
giga chat
sss plus tier super who gets released in
4 will
easily be the best girl of 2020. which
sorry you're kidding i still love you
dearly but right now that person is
chizuru mizuhara
from rent a girlfriend that's it that's
the video
right i guess i'll talk about the show
she's from as well i have been
absolutely addicted to rent a girlfriend
this season and a big part of that is
for introducing me to the best girl of
2020 but beyond that it's also reignited
my love for the harem genre as a whole
see harem is one of those genres in
anime that can be seen as pretty
formulaic with a lot of shows following
the same patterns
same tropes same bland nice guy
protagonist but see rent a girlfriend
is not that much different from one of
those shows but jesus christ i
absolutely cannot stop watching it
anyway because he has a guy who just
can't seem to get a single w in his life
just starting college being dumped by
his first ever girlfriend of only one
month in a desperate attempt to get over
her he does what any guy would do to
move on and what we can all agree
is the most healthy way possible
when in doubt simp your way out cause
hell if there's anything i've ever
learned
money can definitely not buy you love
but i can buy you waifus yes he rents
out our main girl chizuru as a rental
girlfriend has a whale of a time and
even gets a bit of unprotected
hand-holding action then once it's all
over he realizes that it was all just an
act and gets mad that a service he
specifically paid for
gave him a service he specifically paid
for and then he keeps renting her out
again and this is anime so of course it
turns out living next to each other and
both their grandparents actually know
each other and now they think they're
actually dating yada yada you get the
deal
rent a girlfriend tiptoes that line of
pretty much doing everything you want
from the typical harem while sprinkling
in just enough to be able to set itself
apart from the others that have just
recently aired as ridiculous as this
premise is
it sets up an interesting dynamic very
fast while the two want to break off
this premium only fan sponsored
relationship as soon as they can
they are forced to keep up this ruse
while having to negate the risk of the
people around them finding out what's
really going on
and it even has room to add a little bit
of spice into the mix you quickly find
yourself clicking on the next episode
not in the holy crap this show is peak
writing kind of way but in the i know
this is bad for me i should probably
stop
but let me just see what happens next
kind of way the setup is just pure
popcorn trash entertainment and before
we say something like oh
so it's what like the anime version of
ninth day fiance or something
no it's wait a minute [ __ ]
[ __ ] it gives a little more of a hook
than your typical premise but as we all
know the strength of the harem anime is
normally dictated by the strength of its
girls and while there are some shows
that make it super difficult to pick a
side with a delicious spread of almost
equally wonderful
waifus the choices in rent-a-girlfriend
are so top-heavy that it might as well
be like trying to balance the great
pyramids on top of his head
look normally a harem is like a pizza
right each character has a role to play
to make it the perfect slice so you got
the protagonist he's not sourdough he's
not stone-baked he's just a [ __ ]
paper-thin
piss-poor excuse for a base then you got
mommy she's the tomatoes but she's a
[ __ ] half-half squirt of tomato sauce
and that piss-poor base then all the
other girls like that crusty-ass piece
of pepperoni found under the fridge and
all the other toppings are on the pizza
but the cheese oh my [ __ ] god the
cheese
it's the mountain of the highest quality
selection of mixed dairy solids you've
ever seen
we got mozzarella we got goda we got red
leicester bree
even [ __ ] wensleydale so much [ __ ]
cheese
on this [ __ ] pizza so this isn't even
a [ __ ] pizza anymore it's just a
massive mountain of melted cheese with
oh my god it tastes so [ __ ] bad but i
can't stop eating it wait what the [ __ ]
was i talking about again
oh yeah harems so yeah harems
are like hamburgers chizuru is just too
powerful at waifu she's just the perfect
blend of all other trimmings of every
flavor of best girl on the market her
design
is gorgeous people may say she's
slightly tsundere but she gets mad for
perfectly reasonable and legitimate
reasons
and eventually gets over them like a
genuine human being and because she puts
up this front in her girlfriend for hire
business she gets to see
numerous different layers to her
characters when she acts differently
like [ __ ] man all i want now is to watch
a harem with three different cheese
roots got perfect white bread waifu
rented chizuru cute and stylish glasses
and braids college chizuru and
the cherry on top vanilla tundra will
kick your balls and enjoy it
she is a human harem but most of all is
that she somehow manages to be such
top wifi material while still feeling
like a real
girl okay let me just explain myself
without sounding like i've never seen an
actual female in my life some of the
best waifus out there
as great as they are have fantastical
elements or traits that would never work
in the real world
but you can look over them because well
they are
anime characters i love senjukahara but
i'd run a [ __ ] mile if some crazy
chick tried to stay for my face
as much as i love holo i know that
almighty wolf god waifus don't actually
exist
and i'm sure most cinderellas would be
absolutely [ __ ] unbearable in real
life
but comparatively chisely feels oddly
grounded
she doesn't have any over the top traits
she doesn't fall into a specific trope
she just feels like a genuinely cool
girl who's down
to earth and just gets it she's not
unreasonable but not to push over either
she'll stand up for you but also tell
you when you're being a [ __ ] and
despite what people may think of her job
she treats it with true pride and
professionalism she's just a
well-balanced
respectable cool girl and compared to
her i don't even know how there can be
any competition
oh i stepped in [ __ ]
what mommy you mean the snake in human
skin that's like the bastard devil spawn
of mine and spear bro from shield hero
the quiet and shy
chick who i'm just guessing their
personality because they haven't
actually appeared in the anime yet oruca
who let's be honest had the word second
place stamped on her head the moment she
was introduced alright i'll admit she's
not bad by any means
she's another rental girlfriend and
she's cute got that not your emotion but
i'll call you an ichan kind of vibe
going on wouldn't be surprising for
agencies called
renter domestic girlfriends but look all
i'm saying is i don't care what the wiki
said her original hair color was clearly
blue that she just died to cover herself
in water going to the losers bracket if
you know what i'm saying
even after all this chizuru breaks the
system so much that
i don't even want her to win normally in
harem we have a bland but nice enough
protagonist so that people can
self-insert themselves into or will at
least be good enough to end up with the
girl you want to win
but kazuya couldn't be further from that
this man is just a living breath moment
i've never seen a man miss
this much and this isn't a dig at anyone
who's feeling desperate in their love
life like
feeling lonely enough to rent a
girlfriend to help get over a
relationship alright that wouldn't be
the way i would deal with it but i can
get what people can turn to when they're
feeling desperate and lonely enough but
then getting mad that the rental
girlfriend treats them the same way as
other clients
then renting her a second time just to
berate her for doing her job
properly bruh the saying just being
lonely and desperate that's just being a
dick
and this type of behavior isn't just
limited to the first episode you can
make a cinema sin style
channel of all the broth moments this
[ __ ] goes through the daily the
man literally stalks chizzery for an
episode justifying it's the heroic act
for all her fellow clients
self-inserts himself into a situation
that doesn't exist and then just [ __ ]
exposes himself and spills the beans and
in the moment you just have to just like
i don't think i have a breath loud
enough to encapsulate the enormity of
this bra
moment right now
bruh there's no two ways about it he's
just that bad right
makes his grandma sad type rents a
girlfriend lad type has a wankies mad
type but the one thing i can't
appreciate is that we finally have the
harem protagonist who actually thinks
about sex
like most boys would do in a situation
like his in fact they do
everything they can to not hide that
fact like i was pissing myself when they
actually showed a scene of him rubbing
out a fat one
such a fat one in fact that it puts him
into an existential crisis
the series really did just do the
character realizes their true feeling
scene while we get to watch a guy jack
off to completion
why is that another tagline to the show
rent a girlfriend
you get to watch a guy jack off to
completion this is the innovation the
harem genre needed judging by the amount
of tissues he has lying about the dude
should have enough post not clarity to
match the wisdom of a tibetan monk
i mean jesus look at this either he has
the semen bank of a hentai protagonist
or his dna has part horse [ __ ] in it
but the reason he works is that the show
is fully aware of how bad he is
which brings me to the point of why i
can't stop watching this show
and what sets it apart from other harems
kazia as a character isn't irredeemable
but he is
hugely hugely flawed right now every
time you think he's taking one step
forward he proceeds to take two steps
back
he'll show some redeeming qualities here
and there but there are a lot of times
also that even if he does something good
his motivations are questionable at best
or even worse does things where others
have to take the burden for his actions
and he just seems completely unaware of
it
in later episodes kazuya does do some
genuinely nice things and even though it
doesn't mask over how he's acted before
you can see growth starting but look
even though i've just gone off a huge
round on how these are not good people
that doesn't mean they're bad characters
quite the opposite in fact
these characters pretty much do their
job perfectly and not in the
over-the-top anime character kind of way
what makes some of these situations so
maddening to sit through
is that we've probably met people just
like these characters
or maybe more uncomfortably can relate
to some aspects of them ourselves
as much as a [ __ ] stained protagonist i
think kazia is i
kinda get him i've been a horny 20 year
old whose top priority was trying to get
laid
and like a lot of other horny young
adults with zero relationship experience
we can find ourselves doing stupid and
desperate [ __ ]
well i've never [ __ ] stalked a girl i
had a crush on before but my point is
that part of the reason is such a
painful yet addictive watch is that we
can probably understand some of the
mindset of where he's coming from huh
coming i can tell you that some of my
first relationships were disasters
i've definitely put up with people in my
life i really shouldn't have because i
was young and stupid and i've had my own
share of
rough moments i look back on that make
me want to cringe so hard i'd shrivel up
and implode back into my abdomen someone
like mommy isn't an evil anime villain
set on taking over the world
she's just a vain manipulative two-faced
[ __ ] who's one exposed twit longer away
from making a two-hour crocodile
tear-filled apology video i just hope
that kazia realizes that being in the
situation isn't a justification for some
of the shitty things he's done
and what this all results in is an
incredibly addicting watch you're
rooting for kazuya to learn from his
mistakes and become a better person
you're screaming at the screen for him
to not take the mommy bait or cheering
for him when his bros are telling it how
it is
because that's what you would probably
do if you saw your own mates doing the
same [ __ ]
and no matter how much of a train wreck
the situation is you can't help but
press the next episode button to see how
it all gets resolved
yep here i am once again on a runaway
train with no brakes
destination trash build i can honestly
see this title being the next big
romantic comedy i religiously stick to
till the bitter end and a massive part
of that is seeing if kazuya can become
the man who deserves chizuru's affection
and love and i'm hoping for it
praying for it because the best of girls
deserves the best of
[ __ ] boys and right now well don't
just take my word for it i'll let one of
the voice actresses who works in the
bloody show to say it best
oh kazia imagine graduating high school
and studying your ass off to pass the
japanese college entrance exams
finally being able to start working
towards your degree and career only to
find yourself becoming a professional l
taker
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
again thank you for bookwalker for
sponsoring me today
you can check out the back to school
deal right now in the description below
for manga like rental girlfriend and
many other titles don't forget
you can also use coupon code giggup for
five dollars off
and yeah that's pretty much it i'm just
gonna keep it short and sweet today
no further updates feels a bit weird to
think the new season of anime is almost
here and i feel like i've hardly watched
any anime at all this year
but yes that's it from me i've been
gigguk and i'll see you all
next time